so how do you make it
how do you overcome the odds
you've got to be the hardest workers in
the room
and
don't put the opportunity up
at some point you've got to be getting
tired of not being number one you have
to be and you gotta can play angry and I
play Angry now I'm cool and calm with my
Approach and when I step out on my field
which is a set or you know like
and you're always going to have haters
and haters like well
damn man how many movies you're going to
make or how much you're going to do like
you do a lot of I say yes
because my ambition of course why not I
could do it yeah I love what I do and
not only that but in what world do we
not work every day
the prep is where the characters made
the key with me is just always finding
what the anchor is and the an anchor
is
getting up at four o'clock in the
morning every day before anybody else
and grounding my thought process is in
the no one will outwork me
no one all starts with this
two hands putting it to work the gym for
me and this physical activity for is my
anchor and I always you know I would
recommend that for all of you guys in
the room is for us to find that anchor
whether it's hiking or biking or yoga or
meditation or whatever it is because for
me the gym just some sort of physical
activity it anchors my day and then it
allows me to go on and work uh for the
rest of the day it's way more than just
physicality yeah it's way more than just
picking up a weight it's just it is my
balance it's my anchor it's my spiritual
Anchor Mental because what it allows me
to do and we all need this because this
treadmill of life there's no stop button
so it's so crazy
um it just allows me to block out the
noise
and clear my head think about what I
need to do or accomplish or think about
the things I need to accomplish without
the influx of information and people
trying to tug at me absolutely
the thing that has worked for me is to
remember the hard times so before
anything big that would happen I would
always take a moment and I just remind
myself all right I was evicted when I
was 14. we were kicked off the island we
couldn't live in Hawaii had no place to
live a lot of [ __ ] happened then when I
moved to Nashville I was arrested
multiple times by the time I was 16
years old like I remember that
if I were playing on this team but
before I lace up before I get on court
before I play in these big games before
I go to the Staples Center where history
says those are those are historic walls
there at the Staples Center I would
remember that and it allows me then to
be present in the moment and understand
holy [ __ ] this the stuff I have around
me right now this is that I dreamed of
when I was a kid I had a piss poor
senior year zero production
no NFL no combine invite nothing finally
went to the CFL Calgary Stampeders
making 250 a week Canadian
Canadian I had to send that home uh to
my wife at that time I had no money so I
remember that when I got cut from Canada
I had seven bucks in my pocket and I
always tell that story so now my
production company is seven bucks
advertising agency seven bucks
everything is seven bucks
so always remember that what helps me is
to keep the hard times in the front of
my mind because it allows me to go into
these big moments that I've worked my
ass off and you guys have worked your
ass off it allows me to go into these
big moments with a different perspective
what it also does for me and again this
just this is what works for me I keep my
back is up against this mother
every day
it's against him
all but it's up against us because it's
what I believe in and when my back is
against us
then there's nowhere to go but that way
and I got to go that way
and I don't give a who is in front of me
they're not going to stop me so how did
I get here by being the hardest worker
in the room
the one thing that will never ever ever
go away is you get your ass in that
weight groom and you put in the work
that's going to happen when you're 30 40
50 60 that never goes away you either
say I'm done or this whatever is going
on is temporary and it made me up at
some point down the road but I'm not
going to let this opportunity go by
without giving it my all
my dad in his pickup truck came down
four o'clock in the morning picked me up
at in Miami from Tampa we lived in a
little apartment in Tampa he drove down
in his little pickup truck to to Miami
to get me when I was cut from the CFL I
was driving up I-75 to I-75 it's like
especially down in Florida Alligator
Alley I'll never forget it's four
o'clock in the morning I leave home I'm
ready to tackle the world to get after
it achieve my dreams and goals
crushed by 22 23 years old I'm now I got
to move back in with my mom and dad I
played on great teams though wait a
second this is not supposed to be my
future I'm supposed to be in the NFL
right now I'm supposed to be making a
lot of coin and buying my parents
buying me taking care of my wife but it
never happened so I pulled in my wallet
I thought well let me see how much money
I have I opened it up I had a five a one
and change
I'm not around and and I well at least I
rounded up to seven bucks
but I thought I need this I got seven
bucks in my pocket where the do I go now
what do I do if I had to be great at
something I wanted to be great in this
world of Hollywood and movie making and
producing an entertainment I had to
commit that you commit to something
commit to the goal they said what do you
want to accomplish I said I want to
accomplish the world I want the world
and I want I want Will Smith's career
and I said and I mean this respectfully
because I know he's here at this agency
with us I want to do it bigger and
better
and I still had these so put in the hard
work with my two hands and that's it and
that's what it comes down to with you
guys too there's nothing you can't
accomplish I had gone through my first
bout of depression I was 18 years old
after that I think I was 23 then after
that was when I got a divorce so it had
been a learning experience through that
therapy really helped me once I
understood that number one I'm not alone
when it comes to mental struggle and
that we all go through it because
growing up being in a house like my dad
was tough love so sharing feelings and
emotions I didn't have that so I held
everything in and plus I was an only
child I was the strong silent type
meanwhile there was a lot of stuff
happening going on in here for me to
become the man that I am today
fortunately one was one I'm not alone
but then the other side to that it's
like the a side the B side and maybe the
most
maybe the most important side is to
communicate and talk and get it out it's
about being vulnerable and the power of
being vulnerable and something that we
we shy away from certainly men I need to
talk about this I need to talk about
this I need to talk about my issues my
fears my depression and it be okay and
so not only am I okay with it but at
times I actually enjoy it
to be able to get it out especially
publicly and talk publicly too about it
and how important that is too you know
so that's the tricky thing I think as we
all go through this
what I've realized in the past couple of
weeks is it's good to explore these
feelings and feeling a little guilty and
I didn't get a chance to say the things
that I wanted to say or I wish he would
have said the things to me as a father
now as a father of three daughters
um the important critical things that
anchor us that I didn't get from him and
it's okay to explore those feelings but
it's also very important
to heal to make sure that we come back
to an anchoring Foundation of um of
gratitude
gratitude for the for what I was able to
have with him but I would say my work
ethic from my dad my dad always said to
that regardless of what you do in life
and where you go respect is going to be
given when it's earned and you have to
go out and earn it every single day
the importance and the power of finding
your identity and being true to who you
are even in that wild world of pro
wrestling it still applies to everyone
in the room and how powerful that could
be because it was a true shift and click
moment
and I never looked back and I became
fortunately the biggest draw that the
business has ever seen really listen
like become a really good listener and
and it took me a long time to understand
that and how important that was because
when you become a good listener and
you're really listening to your partner
in this relationship of love and spirit
as you talk about then inherently you
become more empathetic and when you
become more empathetic then you just
understand your wife and your partner on
a deeper level on a greater level and
then there's a greater level of
appreciation too as well I want to talk
about these little things and really
truly being in the moment being present
and how important that is and so even
more present because the other stuff I
feel you know the fame and the accolades
and all that stuff is awesome but that
comes and goes
this kind of connection this and what I
have with my family my daughters and
people like that means everything I
still see every opportunity that I have
it's like a little crack in the wall a
little scratch and it's almost as if
like every opportunity represents the
scratch represents every opportunity
therefore the success on the other side
of the scratch is the light
scratching hard clawing digging it's
that mentality to really take advantage
of every opportunity I have